something I i found out here in the
States and especially in Hollywood it's
like that you need to learn how to pitch
yourself and you know here it's a minute
it's a must you need to know how to beat
yourself so that you know you're you can
become very narcissistic and that's
something that happens social networks
oh no you need to always be very careful
because you know is to be to remain
honest and simple unlike not
narcissistic it's very important for
your work i think you know to to keep it
real to stain on it I think it's
important for your work and I think
people are really values that if if
you're close to them if you're not like
a star even though if you are a star you
know if you're really huge but even that
you are able to keep talking to people
like their people and you are just
another person which is who you are I
think people really value that described
is to engage so at some point it doesn't
mean you don't need to sell yourself you
need to but you need to do it in an
honest way it means not don't oversell
just tell what you're doing that I hate
when you know when I'm meeting someone
and it's like he begins to you know tell
me how huge is his work and how amazing
is what he does and you can see it's not
that big you know if you're if you were
that big your work will be talking for
you so I think that's the most important
thing is to let your worktop for you if
if you're doing a great job you can you
can I mean you're going to sell it
you're going to be talking about
yourself and you can pitch you know as
much as you want because it's the work
was talking
you